[Music]
I'm bilingual but I don't speak BS how
are you enjoying this ride or housewife
so far she's mean you know an amazing
time I really have enjoyed so much and
I'm making some lifelong friends so it's
been really fun
not all lifelong friends I don't think
so maybe I mean that's all that you know
I tried to concentrate on the positive
you know and all the good friends that
I'm making the one friend you didn't
make it seems was Leeanne Locken mm-hmm
she told me she felt like you made the
effort to be friends with everyone but
her well you know that's her perspective
I feel like I came in completely trying
to give everyone a chance and I wanted
to you know get to know everybody you
know she was just very difficult to to
get to know so I feel like she just kind
of had a wall actually towards me and
Lee Ann was just you know on the trip to
Mexico she was just on earth which is
really negative so you know I just like
you know when people are like that I
just tend to just ignore them
are you always this negative about
everything yeah not negative you're
always negative you'll be complaining I
got here no I have not you are you're
just like complaining about everything I
mean and I you know and I kept trying to
figure her out and understand her and
every time I would meet with her I would
try to see what was going on and tried
to understand her and her whole
relationship with Diandra you know so I
was really trying to figure it out and
every time I was around her she wouldn't
make it hard to for me to open that door
so you could never really figure it out
as much as you tried I mean I figured
her out I just couldn't figure out ye
you know she just was very yeah - she
was just you know always just got under
my skin the way she explained it to me
and I want to get how you react to this
she said she's an alpha and you think
you're an alpha well I just don't think
that alphas need to say their alphas I
just act like office I lion doesn't have
to say they're a lion they just I'd like
a lion so do you think Leanne's bark is
more than her bite then honestly I don't
know whether she has a bark or why she
likes to think she does but I I mean I
don't know there is a moment where she
really gets in your face and screams at
you I'm the [ __ ] she should tell it -
not you not you not brandy what leads us
to that what's that about we were you
know at her bachelorette party and I was
feeling a little bit at this point you
know it was right after you know
courageous we had this amazing trip in
Mexico and you know her and II I know
seemed to be okay so I thought the
Android really making an effort getting
along with the end when Deandra asked me
if I was gone to the Bachelorette but
yes are you coming and she said no I'm
not going and she didn't invite me so I
can feel a little bit honestly weird
because you know here I'm friends with
Deandra I choose Matt the end I'm
invited my she's mad so I was trying to
figure out why was the Andrew not
invited so I simply Ashley and hey why
is not the Andrew here so you know
Leeanne aliens you know form she you
know gets on my face and screams about
it so I just listen to I didn't there's
also a moment in the trailer where you
are seemingly talking about Lea adding
you say
she likes to give but she cannot take it
and I'm sick of people like that yeah I
mean she loves to criticize and I stick
it to a lot of people but you know when
you do it to her she plays the victim
and oh my gosh makes me the biggest
thing out of it and you know it's just
kind of like okay well at this point
when I say that that was in Thailand so
at that point I'd really had had her
figure out and I'm like okay well she
sure likes to give it but you know when
you do a little bit to her she just
makes this big scene in Christ and oh my
gosh everybody's hard to get but then
why go to her wedding if you're not
clicking well you know I honestly like
when I really really realize that okay
this is not gonna go anywhere was really
in archery trip to Thailand okay so
honestly before that you know we were
she would invite me and she texted me
directly Kay come to my wedding and I
would like for you to be there and ah
you know I had not nothing going on what
took me there because in case you know
we were gonna know I was hoping that we
could be friends and and I know this was
a very important thing for LeAnn so I
wanted to be there you know and but I
didn't really realize that he was really
not gonna happen until Thailand when I
really figure it out okay so you are
trying to work on it trying to make it
work as much as you could and you had a
realization on the big trip at the end
of the season yeah okay now LeAnn has
had this kind of relationship with a lot
of people in this group where it's when
they first get to know where it doesn't
work out and then we come back around
and there is a friendship there so do
you see any chance of you two being
friends or not at all
I'm never gonna say no because you know
you never know and famous last words
right when they say no I will never do
these and you end up being you know
super close to someone I don't like to
have enemies I mean I would like to be
cordial with the end you know it's
really like it's up to her this is my
circus and I need some monkeys
this week brings the return of the other
carry if I understand correctly it's
kind of your entry point into this group
even though she exited the group when
you entered it yeah yeah that was
actually you know a big like when I get
the call I said what the bad news is
that Kari is not gonna be on it anymore
I was like what
so you know that was definitely tough
for our friendship because I know Kerry
didn't think I was my fault
but he still you know she went through
some you know I tough times with that
but we're in a good place now
good this whole process of becoming a
housewife entering this world what has
been the biggest surprise to you of all
this oh wow the biggest surprise I never
expected honestly to make such amazing
friends and you know like I become very
very close like with a couple of girls
it's Stephanie Cameron you know and like
I talked to them almost every day and
how close of friendships you know I
formed in such a short time I'd never
really expected that because going in
you knew Kerry and D'Andra I do know
anybody else I do carry on the Ender but
I would say that my friendships with
Stephanie and Cameron are way stronger
than my friendship with Kerry and Dondre
where ever before Wow
so that's what has been definitely
surprising for sure Spanish is my first
language and people say I have a nice
and when I speak English but I think
I've lost don't you how do you make up
how often your close caption you know
that's so funny because a lot of people
have said that oh my gosh I can't
believe they're putting subtitles on
everything she says you know and some
people have asked me how do you feel
about that I'm like oh you know what
haven't even noticed it like seriously
like it's so funny because I didn't even
notice it and I mean I think you know I
I don't really care either way
okay all right bringing it back to the
season one word to describe what is
still to come how would you sum it up
mmm very unexpected why is it unexpected
well I think there's a lot of like
friendships that kind of shift around
and
and just things that you know happen
that yeah
I was I didn't see coming here's
glimmering your high that it's making me
excited but also nervous yeah
which is that how we should feel about
the rest of season excited but nervous
excited about nervous yeah okay we will
leave it on that excite about nervous
thank you Gary cue up come
[Music]
[Applause]